warning that russia may be changing its
strategy in ukraine a senior u.s defense
official says after weeks of failing to
capture keeve the capital and suffering
heavy losses russian forces are shifting
their ground offensive to the donbass
region in eastern ukraine one of its
strongholds even as it bombards the
country the accusations of russia
committing war crimes are increasing it
is now believed that russia struck
nearly three dozen medical facilities
including hospitals and ambulances in
ukraine mts taiya has more from the
western city of levive this morning mts
good morning to you
good morning well as ukraine continues
to mount a fierce resistance on the
battlefield and russia suffers heavy
losses mosca has announced a new phase
in its brutal war
vladimir putin's military
miscalculations laid bare russian tanks
just outside the capital kiev now burnt
out wrecks of twisted metal as ukrainian
forces continue to fight back
in moscow and surreal stagecraft to
announce what's being called a new phase
of the kremlin so-called special
military operation in ukraine
it's too early to know whether this
apparent change in focus means president
putin is scaling back his brutal
invasion but with nato estimating
between seven and fifteen thousand
russian soldiers killed since fighting
began it's something ukrainian president
vladimir zelinsky is hoping for
in yet another appeal he called on
russia to negotiate meaningfully
urgently and fairly to end the war
a war which has already inflicted so
many horrors particularly on children
just one month into russia's invasion
and over half of all children across
ukraine 4.3 million of them have had to
flee their homes
at train stations around the country
so many agonizing goodbyes as families
are torn apart
[Music]
despite the trauma and kids are still
kids says james elder from unicef who
warns the effects of this conflict could
last for years the longer this goes on
the more likely you get long-term issues
which we know long-term issues are
mental health issues their development
issues
many internally displaced families have
found shelter in schools at one in la
vie we meet 13 year old anastasia who
lives here with her dad and little
brother
i come from melatopal where there was a
lot of russian soldiers she says it took
us two and a half days to get here by
train
anastasia says the hardest thing about
leaving home was saying goodbye to her
grandmother things are really tough
right now but you're still smiling
i don't know she says
i think i do it for my dad
now according to the un 78 ukrainian
children have been killed since the
start of this war and 105 have been
injured now given so many areas are
still inaccessible those numbers they
say are likely far far higher
adriana
oh and ts taya thank you